[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
reisen endlich wieder in die ferne
schweifen
doch wie kehren wir zurück zum
massentourismus
oder werden wir zum individual
abenteurer wie geht reisen in der
zukunft
nordkorea eine diktatur völlig isoliert
vom rest der welt und doch es gibt
ähnlichkeiten zur schweiz unterwegs in
einem land der berge und
im hotel waldhaus wohl bera traf sich im
letzten jahrhundert die hochfinanz mit
dem glamour zur kur
bis
1989 geplante gerettet wurde ein
geheimnis das jetzt gelüftet wird
[Musik]
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja heute
gehen wir der kultur des reisens nach
und haben uns dafür für ein gefährt
entschieden das maximale freiheit
verspricht der wohnwagen allerdings sind
wir damit auch maximal den launen der
natur ausgesetzt und das bekommen wir
heute so richtig zu spüren ja was reisen
seit klimawandel und zeit der pandemie
ganz grundsätzlich bedeutet dieser frage
gehen wir heute nach
[Musik]
bevor ich losfahre treffe ich mich mit
dem mann der mir einen oldtimer
wohnwagen ausleiht und alles übers
kempen weiß
[Musik]
helden von damals ihre starren alte
campari mit aussehen ganz viele woher
kommt ihr wieder schafften die jetzt
schon früh mit dem auto in die ferien
bei debis suchtwoche zum auto passte und
sich einfach im auto wohl gekauft und
restauriert dem wohnblock und maxi camp
er das bedeutet aus sicht der
naturschützer dass ihre spiele über
haben sie der allianz oder andere
anekdote schneller
risikobereit es kommt man im winter und
das altwerden ist zusammenhalt - 560 und
dennis war 2001 alte
plötzlich aber ja mit der heizung ist es
gar nicht so schlecht man dankt sich
maximale freiheit hat war mal mit dem
wohnwagen oder mit dem camper ich das
wirklich ausgedient dritte schweizer ist
das mehr illusionen schöne traum hat
sich natürlich würde zeige der letzten
15 jahre stark verändert so dass wir
wieder punkten entstanden so weiter im
wohnmobil wohnwagen verkauft aber die
filme campingplatz geht sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht was sie wartet
immer voller und
das abenteuer kurzfristig verloren genau
wie viele computer bearish eigentlich
verboten aber waren leber buch haben sie
mich wissen zur verfügung stellt sich
das anders lösen können wir jetzt ein
amerikaner aus klasse was hat denn der
amerikaner soll später in sachen statik
der hat jetzt nicht so viel später wäre
es eigentlich durch linz stehe ich aus
der linie die größere die partie schien
eigentlich alle luxus kann sich dort
zuhause könne wünschte er hätte
einfaches bett zimmer und das wc und das
original nachgerückt war dafür
[Musik]
also nichts wie los unterwegs sein ist
ja bereits die halbe miete sogar bei
diesem wetter mein ziel einen
idyllischen ort in der natur zu finden
und dort einen moment zu verweilen und
darüber zu sinnieren wie sich die kultur
des reisens angesichts von pandemie und
klimawandel wohl für immer verändert hat
[Musik]
träumen sie von ferien am bier
sehnen sich nach entspannung und
erholung
wünschen sich weit weg von allen sorgen
ängsten problemen
doch wo und wie lässt sich unbeschwert
urlaub machen in zeiten wie diesen
und in zukunft
wie viel hat reisen eigentlich mit dem
guten leben zu tun und was ist für mich
gutes leben sie können natürlich gerne
nach gegner fahren und dort an den
strand und schauen wie das gefühl ist
zusammen mit vielen vielen vielen
anderen schweizerinnen und schweizern
das wird super
der historiker valentin groebner hat
noch vor corona ein buch übers wegfahren
und wegfliegen geschrieben über unsere
nimmermüde suche nach dem perfekten
urlaub er kennt kein pardon wenn es um
den ferien zirkus geht
das ist ja eine große
selbstverpflichtung maschine
und plötzlich ist die zum stillstand
gekommen die seit 170 jahren gelaufen
und wir stellen auf einmal fest geht
auch ohne
so ist müdigkeit
für brückner sind ferien großteils eine
anti überdruss maßnahme gegen den
eigenen alltag
ist verreisen wirklich ein akt der
verzweiflung verpackt als belohnung ein
reisen ist viel mehr reisen ist welt
erkundung weltverständnis
herausforderung wachsen lernen all das
es reisen für erik lorenz autor und
erfolgreicher podcaster ist jeder
zurückgelegte kilometer eine nachhaltige
erfahrung in seinem buch welt wach
erzählt er von seinen eigenen abenteuern
und lebens lektionen
vom motorrad trip durch den himalaja der
ihn mut zum wagnis gelehrt habe
von vorstellungen die es galt über bord
zu werfen in einem dorf in laos
auf einer verlotterten farm in
australien oder im iranischen isfahan
selbst wenn man das gefühl hat oder
meint relativ weltoffen durch die gegend
zu gehen man hat ihm doch oft vorurteile
denkmuster
handlungsmuster zu durchbrechen fällt im
alltag wahnsinnig schwer das zu lernen
kann man reisen für leichter gelingen
weil man dann schon fast automatisch aus
seinen üblichen abläufen und
denkprozessen herausgenommen ist muss
man um den globus sausen um
voranzukommen zu wachsen für valentin
groebner kein probates allerwelts mittel
die veränderung auf reisen gibt
und zwar wenn man 19 21 25 ist da
passiert wahnsinnig viel auf reisen wenn
ich mit 50 weg war wiederholt was aber
ich kann mir selber ein reden oder mein
reisebüro tutors dass das ganz neue
erfahrungen sind erfahrungen macht man
dadurch dass man dinge lernt und ich
glaube dass die wesen die meisten
erfahrungen macht man eigentlich dadurch
dass man dinge ausprobiert und arbeitet
und reisen ist das genaue gegenteil von
arbeit es sei denn es ist die eigene
arbeit zu reisen diese reduktion greife
zu kurz jede generation könne aus zwei
drei wochen in der fremde wertvolle
lehren ziehen voraussetzung echtes
interesse an land und leuten
aber wenn ich einmal dagewesen bin
nämlich an gerüche in einen menschen
erinnern die nicht begegnet bin dann
wirklich eine ganz andere partie wenn
ich zum beispiel eine schlagzeile lesen
über irgendeine politische krise oder
einer naturkatastrophe und ich finde ich
diesen orten einfach viel mehr verbunden
und habe dadurch auch das gefühl dass
ich ein stück weltbürger werde auf die
schnelle die welt entdecken und sich
erholen schier unmöglich erst recht
keine lösung eine pauschalreise da sind
sich lorenz und grüttner für einmaleins
der erholungs und erlebnis stress sei
vorprogrammiert ebenso die enttäuschung
überhöhte erwartungen zu glauben bei so
einer reise das einzigartige unberührte
zu finden bei weltweit 1,5 milliarden
touristen im jahr selbstbetrug
auch sehenswürdigkeiten abzuklappern
habe mit welt kennenlernen wenig zu tun
die ihnen die bis februar letzten jahres
nach luzern gekommen sind stehen an
denselben orten und schauen sich
dieselben sachen an wie mark twain und
james fenimore cooper im neunzehnten
jahrhunderts das heißt das ist eine
große rückkopplung
smarter die alle leute schon kennen dazu
dienen selber hin zu fahren und sie sich
nochmal anzuschauen an touristenorten
entsteht nichts neues
reisen damit alles so bleibt wie es ist
keine zukunftsperspektive beim reißen
sollten wir unsere komfortzone verlassen
sogar uns selbst neu kennenlernen für
uns unserer mitmenschen und die welt
eine win win situation schaffen
wie also können wir auch angesichts des
klimawandels all diesen ansprüchen
gerecht werden wir müssen weiter diese
gespräche führen wir müssen weiter das
öffentliche bewusstsein schärfen für
ökologisch und sozial verantwortliches
reisen und das heißt fernreisen
tatsächlich verringern auch wenn es zum
teil auch bedauerlich ist das bedeutet
nach dem abenteuer der haustür ausschau
zu halten und das auch als kreative
herausforderung zu begreifen und das
glaube ich wird auch nach der pandemie
weiterhin eine herausforderung sein hand
aufs herz wie aber schätzen lorenz und
brückner eine vernünftige flug dosierung
nach corona realistisch ein
der hunger rauszukommen und endlich
wieder diese erfahrung machen zu können
der ist so gewaltig dass ich glaube nach
der pandemie werden wir uns einfach
sozusagen wie finger und reisen reisen
beruht auf möglichst großen ökonomischen
unterschieden zwischen den denjenigen
die reisen und diejenigen die bereist
werden weil es bei ihnen ein echter ist
es bei den leuten mit mehr geld wenn
diese unterschiede aufrechterhalten
bleiben in der härte wie wir sie heute
haben wird das reisen weitergehen und
wenn das erdöl weiter billig bleibt die
das ist das alles ermöglicht dann wird
das reisen auch weitergehen welt wach
bleiben verantwortungsvoll das will erik
lorenz valentin grüttners maxime
verschlammten stadt verplanen sein
nächstes projekt mit dem fahrrad ans
meer das ist richtig schön ist's
passiert überhaupt nichts man radelt am
kanälen entlang
und hat
einen großen großen sommer je langsamer
man unterwegs ist desto größer ist das
sommer
[Musik]
mir gefällt es hier draußen sogar bei
diesem wetter ich bin fürs erste im
luzernischen geblieben warum denn in die
ferne schweifen
[Musik]
zwischenstation machen wir hier am
rankbach am fuße des pilatus und um
berge geht es auch bei uns im nächsten
beitrag wenn auch in einem land das kaum
jemand auf seiner reise wunschliste
führen dürfte nordkorea bekannt aus
diktatur dass seine bevölkerung
unterdrückt und dem westen mit
atomwaffen droht doch nordkorea ist auch
ein land der berge ein team des alpinen
museums bern ist ins land der sehr
begrenzten möglichkeiten gereist
nordkorea
eine abgeschottete diktatur führerkult
unterdrückung armut
und doch hat das verfemte land etwas das
es auszeichnet und mit der schweiz
verbindet berge
nordkorea ist dreimal so groß wie die
schweiz und besteht zu 80 prozent aus
hügeln und bergen von
dieser gemeinsamkeit profitierten bert
hechler direktor des alpinen museums in
bern und der filmemacher denn so nah
ihre ausstellung über nordkoreas berge
will den stereotypen blick auf das
isolierte land mit neuen einsichten
erweitern
das ist gar nicht vor froh im kopf dass
des ortes nordkoreas einfach nordkorea
solches politisches system wer das land
wo berge etzelsberger nur einfaches
geologisches phänomen sondern sind mit
identität verknüpft mit politik mit
geschichte kulturhistorisch und in
nordkorea ist es durch der politischen
fleißig ist es sehr sehr spürbar die
ganze zeit es sollte ihr bisher
aufwendigste projekt werden
2018 und 2019 noch vor corona begab sich
das schweizer team zweimal ins land der
begrenzten möglichkeiten
eng begleitet von guides des regimes
jeder schritt zuvor abgesprochen
jeder kontakt zu gesprächspartnern vom
cultural komitee in pjöngjang abgesegnet
dennoch kommt es zu spontanen interviews
etwa mit privilegierten einheimischen
touristen auf dem kumgang seien
an der grenze zu südkorea
[Musik]
der ungefragte dank an die großen führer
ein immer wiederkehrendes muster in den
gesprächen die das schweizer team in
nordkorea führte
will eigentlich das kollektiv
im interview
politische korrektheit
der peg tucson mit rund 2750 metern
höchste berg des landes gipfel der
indoktrinierung alle müssen einmal hier
oben gewesen sein
der berg ist besetzt von personenkult
und die herrscherdynastie der kim
familie und wird glorifiziert als wiege
des unabhängigkeitskampfes gegen fremde
mächte
[Musik]
die politische mystifizierung beginnt
schon im frühesten kindesalter und
geht nahtlos weiter in der schulischen
erziehung
wo die luft dünner wird schwebt der
geist des sozialismus nordkoreanischer
prägung man stärkt den revolutionären
glauben im himmel sei alles hier
verströmt eine beinahe heilige aura
manches in der ausstellung klingt
unbeholfen heruntergeleitet bestätigt
die vorurteile und doch beginnt man sich
für die menschen zu interessieren
wie sind sie angezogen wie frei können
sie sich überhaupt bewegen was denken
sie wirklich
filmen durften die macher eben nur was
dem regime genehm war die spielregeln
waren von anfang an klar gelingt es über
das thema berge näher an die menschen
heranzukommen es geht aufnahme in der
berger im stadtpark plötzlich überrascht
ist wie ein licht das muss aber das geht
auch viel moment wo auch edith
aktionspotenzial hand und wo man die
bautiefe strikt zwischen bürgern politik
sehr spürt und dass dieser gewichtig ist
das aber nicht einfach das kommentiere
oder zweiter sondern wirklich die frage
wo es ständig begleitet händen ganz
realisation prozess der frau gewittert
es gehe an besucherinnen und besucher
und das sagte diskurs dritter
stattfindet wo ich bin erstaunt darüber
dass das auch nordkoreas wodurch sein
bestätige und das ist einfach so kinder
permanent ab gemacht und ich glaube dass
mir mein geschaut realisiert dass mir
eigentlich schon extrem wenig wisse
auch wenn es schwierig war an die
menschen heranzukommen ein ski resort
wie dieses sagt viel aus über ein land
das sich abschottet und doch zur welt
dazu gehören will
in dieser architektonischen einöde
erlebt das team einen seltenen moment
eines persönlichen bekenntnissen
es gibt sie die sehnsucht über die
eigenen berge hinauszuschauen
doch wie stark lässt sich die begrenzung
der diktatur im kopf überwinden
[Musik]
was weiß man in nordkorea über die welt
die korona krise hat die isolation
nordkoreas noch verstärkt ein glücksfall
in diese seltenen eindrücke eintauchen
zu können
[Musik]
denn so rasch wird eine solche reise
wohl nicht mehr möglich sei
[Musik]
hier habe ich mein plätzchen gefunden
irgendwo im luzerner hinterland habe ich
einen lieben bauer gefragt der mir seine
wiese zur verfügung stellt
[Musik]
und jetzt reisen wir in die
vergangenheit in die gloriosen zeiten
der schweizer hotellerie wer es sich
leisten konnte reiste zur kur in der
ersten hälfte des letzten jahrhunderts
war besonders gerne ins engadin
ein hotspot des badetourismus war das
prächtige hotel waldhaus in vulgärer
1989 brannte es ab aber etwas überlebte
den brand nämlich die gästekarte mit
20.000 karten
[Musik]
27 mai 1989 kurz vor sechs uhr früh
das kartell waldhaus in volterra steht
in flammen und brannte bis auf die
grundmauern nieder
führen er hätte jeder mann schlug mir
händ ist denn du dir keller gearbeitet
und bin richtig warm für kürzen ein
radfahrer spritzer bis ein mitarbeiter
die kommt rät keller aber und zeit
irgendwie immer spritzer essig bereits
in vollbrand
32 jahre später bleibt die relikte ein
paar säulen schalen und eine mauer
[Musik]
das waldhaus war ein fünf sterne luxus
betrieb ein hotel mit 300 betten und 300
angestellten geöffnet jeweils von mai
bis september
er baut ende des 19 jahrhunderts vom
schweizer architekten niklas hartmann
bot es alle nur erdenklichen
annehmlichkeiten für die internationale
obwohl
das war einfach ein schmelztiegel ein
treffpunkt und die hatten ja ganz weite
anreisen sind ganze welt gekommen von
südamerika und afrika gab es nicht
glauben können dass sie sind beide sehr
und getreten haben allein von landeck
haben die acht stunden mit der
postkutsche gebraucht bis sie da im
unterengadin angekommen sind
der mondäne betrieb florierte das image
stieg stetig die illustren gäste blieben
wochenlang
intern wurde die klientel von personal
dabei kritisch beobachtet gelauscht
bespitzelt und dieses betriebsinterne
wissen wurde auf den karteikarten der
gäste in einer art blacklist notiert
kurz scharf und mitunter zynisch
[Musik]
jahrzehnte lagerten die karteikarten der
jahre 1921 bis 1961 externe und konnten
so den flammen entkommen
verschiedene geheimcodes mussten die ski
fährt werden recherchen des fotografen
des hechenblaikner und der
kulturwissenschaftlerin andrea kühbacher
ergaben dass die abkürzung tiroler für
jüdische gäste und ihre
geschäftstüchtigkeit verwendet wurde
und auch das kürzel pi mit den
steigerungs formen verwendet für
palästina schweizer zeugt von einer
deutlichen antisemitischen haltung des
personals
die namen sind nicht geschmerzt weil
hinter den namen personen stehen und
geschichten stehen und es ist ja nicht
wichtig was über die leute
gesagt wurde ob das jetzt wahr ist oder
nicht weil es das kennen wir nicht
überprüfen sondern wir können nur sehen
wie wurden sie wahrgenommen und wie hat
man sie eingeschätzt
und das sagte viel mehr über den
schreiber der karteikarten aus als über
den beschriebenen es geht hier darum was
vermerke ich was aber richtig bei
anderen
auch in den dreißiger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts vor und während des zweiten
weltkriegs verkehrten juden im waldhaus
zur gleichen zeit wie die nazis
[Musik]
es treffen die henker auf ihre späteren
opfer
bis dann die juden ganz ausbleiben
finde karstadt ja und sie interessanten
wie sind mit blei stiftung führt stadt
reist
und liefert eine karte und wenn man das
musst du dir kennt die habe ich da in
der hand kauter die hände nahm und den
einfach mit dem adresse er ist ob sie
wieder trister jahre und am ende statt
einfach mit bleistift verreist ist ein
menge von der kraft wenn ich mal
alleingang und hinten einfach müssen
feststellen dass irgendein verein lager
und pracht worden sind und das stimmt
schon nachdenklich
waldhaus gast war auch der schweizer
schriftsteller friedrich dürrenmatt er
holte sich im grund helfer seinen
letzten
1989 erschienenen roman durcheinander
tal maßgeblicher inspirationen
also durcheinander
die wirklichkeit sogar mit ihren
fantasie durch da brennt ein
ja das war das natürlich weil wir
eigentlich dort hatte ich die idee bei
ihnen prinzip uns wirklich abgebracht
eine explosion erschütterte die nacht
eine stichflamme schoss in den himmel
die sterne verschwanden das ganze haus
stand mit einem mal in flammen der
damalige direktor glaubte nicht an einen
zufall
es gibt das zu erfahren dass einen das
buch schrieb das buch wird war monate
nach dem brand öffentlicht uns huus
brennt ab in der seite burschenschafter
school der türkei verhaftet weil eine
menge dienst bietet seit sechs
jahrzehnten und das hat mich ich habe
das nicht sein ich sage es geht zu
erfahren fakt ist dürrenmatt entwarf
seine geschichte jahrzehnte vorher
das waldhaus war immer schon treffpunkt
nicht nur für literatur giganten die
geheimen karteikarten sind zeugnisse mit
sprengkraft eine art dna der
tourismuswirtschaft mit emotionen und
krimispannung gespickt die rund
zehnjährige projekt recherche des
tiroler fotografen zum buch ist eine art
fantasie beflügeln maschine
ein hotel ist einfach immer auch ein
geheimnisträger weil das kann man so
will geschichten zusammen menschen die
aufeinander prallen immer in einer
anderen konstellation mit dem personal
und wo menschen sind müssen geschichten
bleiben
bleibt zu klären warum eigentlich keine
ostergrüße mehr notiert wurde
dieser code stand für maximalen
liebesentzug und garantierte dieser gast
kommt sicher nicht mehr
[Musik]
ja ich mache es mir da ein bisschen
gemütlich und zidan morgen weiter mark
twain übrigens er hatte das luzernische
auch geliebt und von ihm stammt der satz
wir müssen reisen um zu lernen das geht
auch ohne flugzeug würde vielleicht
heute hinzufügen ja wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]